Greetings student
doctors. My name
is Dr. Bradley
Hickey. I'm an
assistant professor
of clinical
medicine here at
the Arkansas campus.
It's my pleasure
to introduce you to
this foundational
lecture in immunology.
The title of today's
follow-on lecture is
Immunogenetics,
Lymphocyte Activation,
Immune Regulation,
and Tolerance Part 2.
this lecture emphasizes
rules and logic over
memorization if you
understand the constraints
the immune system
operates under the
details that will come
later will make much
more sense you'll also
notice this lecture
is relatively graphic
light that is intentional
the goal today is to
build the conceptual
scaffolding first once
you understand the
rules the system
follows the diagrams and
later lectures become
much easier to interpret
orientation from
recognition to response
in the previous lecture
we focused on how
the immune system
recognizes antigen and
decides whether a
response should begin that
decision point is
critical but is often only
the beginning of an
immune response in this
lecture we shift
attention to what happens
after a lymphocyte
has been activated
specifically we will
examine how immune responses
are expanded shaped
restrained and eventually
resolved these
downstream processes
determine whether immune
activation is protective
ineffective or harmful
understanding this
progression is essential
for interpreting
immune mediated
disease a useful way to
anchor this idea is to
ask what problem is the
immune system trying
to solve and what why
is the solution safer
than the alternatives
a practical test of
understanding is to
explain this in one
sentence without jargon
then restate it with
the correct technical
term if you can do both
you own the concept
learning objective
objectives and conceptual
roadmap the purpose
of today's session is
to understand how immune
activation translates
into functional
outcomes we will discuss
clonal expansion
differentiation into effector
cells the formation
of immunologic memory
and mechanisms that
limit responses rather
than focusing on
lists of subsets the
emphasis will be on why
the immune system regulates
these processes so
carefully each step
represents a trade-off
between effectiveness
and safety by the end
of this lecture you
should be able to
explain not just what
happens after activation
but why it happens
focus on the functional
logic what input is
being sensed what
decision is being made and
what output follows
from the decision notice
the theme specificity
gives power but
regulation provides safety
almost every mechanism
and adaptive immunity
reflects that
trade-off clonal selection
as a foundational
principle adaptive
immunity operates on the
principle of clonal
selection only lymphocytes
with receptors
capable of recognizing
a specific antigen are
selected to participate
in an immune
response this ensures
specificity but it also
creates a logistical
problem at the start
of a response antigen
specific lymphocytes
are extremely rare.
The immune system must
therefore amplify these
rare cells to have
a meaningful effect.
If you feel the
details blurring
together, return to
the core question,
what changes in
the cell after this
step and what was
not true before?
A quick contrast here
may help. If this
step were missing, the
response would either
be too weak to clear
the threat or too
strong and damaging
to the host therefore
the immune system is
constantly avoiding both
errors why clonal
expansion is essential
recognition of
antigen alone does not
control infection or
disease a single antigen
specific lymphocyte
cannot clear pathogens
or coordinate immune
defenses clonal
expansion solves this
problem by generating
large numbers of
identical cells. This
expansion allows the
immune system to deploy
sufficient force at
the site of infection.
Because expansion is
costly and potentially
dangerous, it is
tightly regulated.
A common learning
trap is to memorize
terms without
a mental model.
Try to picture the
following sequence.
A signal leads to a
decision, and that decision
leads to a behavior,
and a behavior leads
to a consequence or
an outcome clinically
the relevance is that
small shifts in this
checkpoint can move a
patient from protection
to pathology we will
repeatedly use this
logic in autoimmunity
chronic inflammation and
transplant rejection
signals that support
expansion clonal expansion
requires more than
antigen recognition
co-stimulatory signals
and cytokines provide
additional instructions
that promote survival
and proliferation.
These signals ensure
that expansion occurs
only in appropriate
inflammatory contexts.
Without these
reinforcing signals,
lymphocytes may fail to
expand or may
undergo apoptosis.
This requirement
helps prevent
inappropriate
immune activation.
A useful way to anchor
this idea is to ask,
what problem is the
immune system trying to
solve here and why is
this solution safer
than the alternatives
differentiation giving
cells functional
identity as lymphocytes
proliferate they do
not remain functionally
identical differentiation
programs determine what
tasks the cells will
perform some cells
become cytotoxic others
provide help and others
coordinate immune
responses this functional
specialization allows
the immune system to
respond appropriately
to different threats
differentiation is
therefore a central
feature of adaptive
immunity focus on this
functional logic what
input is being sensed
what decision is being
made and what output
follows from that decision
functional diversity
of effector cells
effector cells represent
the working units of
the immune response
different Immune
effector programs are
suited to different
immunologic challenges.
This diversity allows
immune responses
to be tailored
rather than uniform.
Understanding effector
diversity prevents
oversimplified views
of immune function.
It also explains
why immune responses
vary across
different diseases.
Memory as a deliberate
immune strategy.
Not all activated
lymphocytes become
short-lived effectors.
Some are programmed
to persist long-term
as memory cells.
Memory cells
allow the immune
system to respond
more rapidly
upon re-exposure
to an antigen.
This is not an
accidental byproduct of
activation, but a
deliberate strategy.
Immunologic memory
is a defining
feature of
adaptive immunity.
The need for controlled
contraction. Immune
responses must eventually
be scaled back.
Persistent activation
can cause tissue
damage and chronic
inflammation.
The immune
system, therefore,
incorporates
mechanisms to contract
responses once threats
are controlled.
This contraction
preserves tissue
integrity and
prevents pathology.
Failures in
contraction contribute
to immune
-mediated disease.
Preview regulation and
tolerance mechanisms
later in this lecture
we will examine
mechanisms that
actively regulate
immune responses these
include tolerance
pathways that prevent
responses against
self tissues such
mechanisms ensure that
powerful immune
responses remain directed
outward understanding
regulation is
essential for
understanding autoimmunity
transition from
activation to expansion.
Once a lymphocyte has
received the appropriate
activation signals,
the immune response
enters a fundamentally
different phase.
Up to this point,
the immune system has
been deciding whether
a response should
occur at all. After
activation, the question
then becomes how
large the response
should be and how much
damage is acceptable.
This transition commits
the immune system
to significant cellular
and metabolic investment
because these
investments carry risk
they are not taken
lightly errors at this
stage can result in
ineffective immunity or
excessive inflammation
and tissue injury the
immune system
therefore regulates the
transition from activation
to expansion very
tightly clonal expansion
as a quantitative
solution clonal expansion
solves a fundamental
quantitative
limitation of adaptive
immunity. At the beginning
of an immune response,
antigen-specific
lymphocytes are extremely
rare. Even if a
lymphocyte is perfectly
specific, a single cell
cannot meaningfully
alter disease course.
Clonal expansion
generates large numbers
of identical daughter
cells from this rare
starting population.
This amplification
transforms molecular
recognition into a
clinically relevant response
without clonal expansion
adaptive immunity
would be precise
but ineffective thus
expansion is essential
for immune success
metabolic demands of
rapid proliferation rapid
clonal expansion places
extraordinary metabolic
demands on lymphocytes
resting lymphocytes
are metabolically
quiet and energy
efficient activation
forces a shift towards
increased glucose uptake
protein synthesis and
biosynthesis this
metabolic reprogramming
supports rapid cell
division such a shift is
energetically expensive
and potentially
dangerous the immune
system therefore restricts
this metabolic transition
to appropriately
activated cells this
requirement protects
against uncontrolled
proliferation cytokines
as drivers of
expansion cytokines are
central regulators of
clonal expansion they
provide survival signals
that prevent apoptosis
during rapid
proliferation they also
promote cell cycle
entry and progression
different cytokine
environments influence the
magnitude and duration
of expansion this allows
immune responses to
scale according to
threat severity cytokine
signaling therefore
integrates environmental
context into
expansion decisions
expansion is never purely
autonomous effector
commitment during expansion
clonal expansion
is not simply about
increasing cell numbers
as lymphocytes proliferate
they begin committing
to specific
effector programs signals
encountered during
activation and early
expansion influence this
commitment. These
signals determine what
functions the cells
will perform in tissues.
Effector identity
is therefore shaped
early, not after
expansion is complete.
This timing ensures
that function matches
inflammatory context.
Expansion and
differentiation are
inseparable processes.
CD8 T-cell effector
differentiation.
Activated CD8 T
-cells differentiate
into cytotoxic
effector cells. These
cells acquire
specialized machinery for
killing infected
or abnormal cells.
Differentiation is
guided by signals
present during
activation and
proliferation. This
ensures cytotoxic
capacity is deployed
selectively.
Unregulated cytotoxic
differentiation can
cause tissue damage. The
immune system therefore
tightly controls this
process precision
is critical clinically
the relevance is that
small shifts in this
checkpoint can move a
patient from protection
to pathology once
again we repeatedly use
this logic in autoimmunity
chronic inflammation
and transplant
rejection CD4 t-cell
differentiation pathways
Activated CD4 T
-cells differentiate
into multiple helper
T-cell subsets.
Each subset
supports a different
type of immune response.
Differentiation
depends on cytokine
signals encountered
during activation.
These signals
provide contextual
information about the
nature of the threat.
This allows CD4
T-cells to tailor
immune responses
appropriately.
Understanding these
pathways prevents
oversimplified views
of helper function.
Functional diversity
is essential.
Why effector
differentiation
must be regulated.
Effector differentiation
determines how
immune responses
affect host tissues.
Overly aggressive
effector programs
can cause
collateral damage.
Insufficient
differentiation may lead to
ineffective pathogen
clearance. the immune
system must balance
effectiveness with
safety regulatory
mechanisms modulate
differentiation outcomes
this balance is a
recurring theme in
immunology disease
often reflects failure
of regulation linking
expansion to immune
function the expanded
lymphocyte
population determines
downstream immune
behavior. Both the size and
composition of this
population matters.
An adequately sized but
poorly differentiated
response may still
fail. Conversely,
excessive
expansion can cause
pathology. This linkage
emphasizes coordinated
regulation. Expansion
and effector
function cannot be
separated conceptually.
They form a single
functional unit.
Preparing for memory
and contraction.
Even as expansion
occurs, the immune
system prepares for
response termination.
Not all expanded cells
will persist long term.
Signals during expansion
influence which
cells become memory
cells. Others are
destined for elimination
during contraction.
These early
decisions shape
future immune
responsiveness.
Understanding this
prepares us for memory
and tolerance mechanisms
this sets the stage
for the next section
expansion is followed
by contraction clonal
expansion cannot continue
indefinitely once
antigen burden is
reduced maintaining
large numbers of effector
cells becomes unnecessary
and dangerous the
immune system therefore
initiates a contraction
phase during
contraction the majority
of effector undergo
program cell death this
process restores immune
homeostasis failure
of contraction can lead
to chronic inflammation
or tissue injury thus
contraction is an
active and essential
phase of the immune
response why contraction
is not immune failure
at first glance
contraction may appear
counterproductive however
elimination of excess
effector cells is a
sign of successful
successful immune
regulation the immune system
must balance pathogen
clearance with
preservation of host
tissues sustained effector
activity in the absence
of antigen would be
harmful contraction
ensures that immune
responses are proportional
and self-limited this
principle applies
broadly across adaptive
immunity understanding
this reframes how we
interpret immune
resolution memory cell
survival during contraction
not all lymphocytes
are eliminated during
contraction a small
subset survives and
differentiates into
memory cells these
cells retain antigen
specificity but adopt a
different functional state
memory cells are
metabolically distinct
from effector cells
they are optimized for
longevity rather than
immediate function this
selective survival
is tightly regulated
memory formation is
therefore a very deliberate
outcome effector versus
memory cell fates
effector and memory
cells arise from
the same activated
precursors their divert
Divergent fates
reflect differences
in signaling and
metabolic programming.
Effector cells
prioritize immediate
function and
rapid activity.
Memory cells prioritize
survival and
rapid recall.
The immune system invests
in both strategies.
This dual outcome
ensures both short-term
protection and long
-term preparedness.
Balance between these
fates is essential.
Signals that Promote
Memory Formation
Signals encountered
during activation
and expansion
influence memory fate.
Cytokine
environment plays a
major role in
this decision.
Strength and duration of
antigen exposure
also matters.
These signals shape
gene expression
and metabolic
programming.
Memory formation
is not a random
event. It reflects
integration
of multiple
environmental cues.
This explains the
variability in
immune memory.
Functional advantages
of memory cells.
Memory cells respond
more rapidly upon
re-exposure to
antigen. They require
less co-stimulation
than naive cells.
This allows faster
immune activation.
Memory responses
are often
stronger and
more efficient.
These features underline
vaccine effectiveness.
However,
memory must still
be regulated.
Uncontrolled
recall responses
can cause pathology.
Homeostatic maintenance
of memory pools.
Memory cells
persist long after
antigen clearance.
They are maintained
through homeostatic
signals rather
than continuous
antigen exposure.
Cytokines support
survival without inducing
full activation.
this allows long-term
persistence without
inflammation homeostasis
prevents gradual loss
of immune protection
disruption of these
signals can impair
immunity this highlights
ongoing regulation
even in health in
this step if this step
were missing the
response would either be
too weak to clear the
threat or too strong
and damaging to the
host the immune system
is constantly avoiding
both errors recognition
is not the same
as activation and
activation is not the
same as effector function
immune resolution
as an active process
resolution of immune
responses is not passive
it requires coordinated
signals and cellular
cellular decisions
effector elimination
memory preservation
and tissue repair occur
simultaneously these
processes must be
synchronized poor
coordination leads to chronic
inflammation resolution
is therefore as complex
as activation this
reframes how we view
immune shutdown
clinical implications of
failed contraction
failure of contraction
contributes to immune
mediated disease persistent
effector activity can
drive chronic inflammation
this is seen in
autoimmune and
inflammatory disorders
understanding contraction
mechanisms helps explain
disease persistence
therapeutic strategies
often aim to restore
regulation this links
basic immunology
to clinical practice
contraction failure
is clinically relevant
from a system's
perspective this is a
control loop the immune
system measures
condition responds and
then applies braking
to prevent overshoot
transition to tolerance
and regulation
contraction and memory
formation lead naturally
into tolerance
mechanisms the immune
system must ensure
responses remain directed
against appropriate
targets tolerance
prevents immune attack
against self tissues
failures of tolerance
underlie autoimmunity
the next section
will focus on how
tolerance is established
and maintained this
transition completes
the response lifecycle
we now shift our focus
to regulation why
tolerance is required
adaptive immunity
relies on highly specific
antigen receptors
this specificity
creates the risk that
some receptors will
recognize self antigens
without tolerance
mechanisms immune
responses could easily
damage host tissues
tolerance ensures
that potentially self
-reactive lymphocytes
are controlled this
protection is essential
for survival in a
complex organism
tolerance is therefore a
foundational feature
of adaptive immunity
failure of tolerance
underlies autoimmune
diseases central vs
peripheral tolerance
tolerance mechanisms
operate at multiple levels
central tolerance
occurs during lymphocyte
development peripheral
tolerance controls
mature lymphocytes
in the periphery each
layer addresses different
vulnerabilities in
the immune system
together they provide
redundant protection
against autoimmunity no
single mechanism is
sufficient on its own
this layered design
reflects the importance
of self-tolerance
central tolerance and t
-cell development central
tolerance for t-cells
occurs in the thymus
developing t-cells
are tested for their
ability to recognize self
MHC cells that cannot
recognize self MHC
are eliminated this
ensures that mature t
-cells can interact
with antigen presenting
cells however this
process also carries risk
excessive recognition
must also be controlled.
This leads to further
selection steps.
Negative selection
and self-reactivity.
eliminates T-cells
that bind self
-antigens too strongly.
Strong binding
indicates a high risk of
autoimmunity. These
cells undergo apoptosis
during development.
This process removes the
most dangerous self
-reactive clones. however
it cannot eliminate all
self reactivity some
potentially reactive
cells escape into the
periphery this
necessitates peripheral
tolerance mechanisms
peripheral tolerance an
ongoing requirement
peripheral tolerance controls
mature lymphocytes
after they leave primary
lymphoid organs self
antigens are encountered
throughout life
new self reactive
specificities may arise
peripheral tolerance
prevents activation of
these cells mechanisms
include energy deletion
and regulation this
ensures long-term immune
stability peripheral
tolerance is dynamic
energy is a tolerance
mechanism energy
refers to functional
inactivation of lymphocytes
anergic cells survive
but do not respond
antigen stimulation
this often occurs when
antigen recognition
happens without co
-stimulation the immune system
interprets such encounters
as non-threatening
energy prevents
inappropriate activation
this mechanism
reinforces the importance
of context signal
integration is central to
tolerance regulatory
T cells and immune
control regulatory T
cells active regulatory T
cells provide active
suppression of immune
responses they limit
excessive activation
and prevent autoimmunity
these cells function
through multiple
mechanisms they modulate
antigen presenting
cells and effector
lymphocytes regulatory
t-cells are essential
for immune homeostasis
their absence leads to
severe immune dysregulation
they represent
active immune restraint
Fox p3 and regulatory
t-cell identity
forkhead box p3 also
known as Fox p3 is a
transcription factor
critical for regulatory
t-cell development it
controls gene programs
required for suppressive
function loss of Fox
p3 disrupts immune
regulation this
highlights the importance
of transcriptional
control regulatory
identity is actively
maintained this is not a
passive cell state Fox
p3 is the central to
tolerance consequences
of failed regulation
when regulatory
mechanisms fail immune
responses become
uncontrolled this can result
in autoimmune disease
or chronic inflammation
clinical syndromes
reflect breakdowns and
tolerance pathways
understanding regulation
explains disease
mechanisms it also helps
inform therapeutic
strategies restoring
regulation is often a
treatment goal thus this
connects immunology
to clinical medicine
integration of tolerance
with immune responses
tolerance mechanisms
operate alongside
activation and effector
function they do
not simply shut the
immune system off instead
they shape responses
to be appropriate
this integration preserves
protective immunity
immune regulation is
therefore contextual.
Balance is the central
theme. This prepares
us next for
transplantation immunology.
B-cell tolerance,
parallels and
differences.
Tolerance mechanisms are
not limited to T-cells.
B-cells also generate
highly specific
antigen receptors.
This specificity
creates similar
risks for cell-free
activity. However,
B-cell tolerance
operates through
distinct mechanisms.
Understanding these
differences is essential
for a complete view
of immune regulation.
B cell tolerance
complements
T cell tolerance.
Together they protect
against autoimmunity.
Central B cell tolerance
in the bone marrow.
Central tolerance
for B cells occurs in
the bone marrow.
Developing B cells are
tested for reactivity
against self-antigens.
Strongly self
-reactive cells
are eliminated
or altered.
This process
removes the most
dangerous clones.
Unlike T-cells, B
-cells can modify
their receptors.
This adds an additional
layer of protection.
Central tolerance is
therefore flexible.
Receptor editing is a
unique B-cell strategy.
Receptor editing
allows B-cells to
change antigen
specificity. This occurs
through additional
gene rearrangements.
Editing reduces
cell-free activity
without eliminating
the cell.
This strategy
preserves useful
cells while
reducing risk.
Receptor editing has
no direct parallel on
T-cell development. It
highlights functional
differences between
lymphocyte lineages.
This mechanism expands
tolerance capacity.
Peripheral B-cell
tolerance mechanisms.
Some self
-reactive B cells
escape central tolerance.
Peripheral tolerance
mechanisms control
these cells.
These mechanisms include
energy and deletion.
Lack of
appropriate T cell
help is also critical.
This interdependence
links B cell
tolerance to T
cell regulation.
Peripheral control
is ongoing.
Tolerance is lifelong.
why t-cell help is
required for antibody
responses most antibody
responses require t
-cell help this requirement
acts as a safety
checkpoint self-reactive
b-cells are very
unlikely to receive help
this prevents auto auto
antibody production
the immune system thus
integrates multiple
safeguards loss of t
-cell help regulation
contributes to autoimmunity
this principle
reinforces the layered
tolerance approach
introduction to transplantation
immunology
transplantation introduces
foreign tissues into the
host the immune system
recognizes these
tissues as non-self this
recognition triggers
immune responses unlike
pathogens transplanted
tissues persist.
This creates a unique
immunologic challenge.
Understanding
transplantation requires
applying tolerance
concepts. This is
a clinically
important application.
Allo recognition, direct
and indirect pathways.
T-cells can recognize
transplanted
tissue through
different mechanisms.
Direct allo recognition
involves recognition
of donor MHC molecules.
Indirect allo
recognition involves
processing donor
antigens by recipient
cells both pathways
activate recipient t
-cells these mechanisms
contribute to rejection
understanding them
explains transplant
outcomes they illustrate
immune sensitivity
types of transplant
rejection transplant
rejection occurs in
different temporal
patterns. These include
hyperacute, acute,
and chronic rejection.
Timing provides clues to
the underlying pathology.
Thus, this classification
guides clinical
management.
Rejection is an
immunologic process.
It reflects failure
of tolerance.
Immunosuppression
and its trade-offs.
Preventing rejection
requires
immunosuppression.
These therapies reduce
immune activation.
However, they also
increase infection risk.
Balancing suppression and
protection is
challenging.
This tradeoff reflects
fundamental
immune principles.
Clinical
decisions involve
managing the above risks.
Immunology
informs therapy.
Integration of tolerance
and clinical practice.
Tolerance mechanisms
are central
to many clinical
contexts.
Autoimmunity,
transplantation, and chronic
inflammation all involve
tolerance failures.
Understanding these
mechanisms aids
clinical reasoning.
Rather than memorizing
diseases, focus
on the mechanisms.
This approach scales
across various
specialties.
Immunology provides
a unifying framework.
Integration is key.
Key concepts.
Immune responses involve
activation, expansion,
differentiation,
and regulation.
Tolerance
mechanisms prevent
immune-mediated damage.
Memory formation
preserves
protective immunity.
Regulation
ensures balance.
failures of these
processes caused disease
and these principles
recur throughout
medicine therefore
they form a conceptual
foundation closing
and forward look this
lecture completes the
core adaptive immune
response sequence
subsequent lectures will
build on these
principles keeping these
mechanisms in mind will
aid your integration
of the knowledge
immunology is cumulative
each layer depends
on the previous one
understanding these
mechanisms improves your
retention in summation
adaptive immunity
requires controlled
amplification antigen
recognition alone
is insufficient to
control infection clonal
expansion converts
rare antigen specific
lymphocytes into
effector populations
differentiation assigns
specialized effector
and helper functions.
Expansion without
regulation
leads to host
tissue damage.
Summary point two.
Regulation and
tolerance are essential
for immune safety.
Contraction actively
terminates immune
responses after
pathogen control.
Memory preserves
protection while
minimizing ongoing
activation.
Central and
peripheral tolerance
prevent immune
responses to self. And
regulatory mechanisms
balance protection
with long-term
tissue integrity.
At the bottom of
the slide you'll
note core references
where you can
seek out additional
information.
This concludes today's
lecture. Thank you
for your time and as
always I welcome your
feedback helping me make
these lectures better.
Thank you and hope
you have a great day.